when your child learns english with the
british council they learn so much more
than a language our classes go further
so they can too primary plus is crafted
for children aged 6 to 11 to help them
express themselves confidently and set
them on a path to success
helping children feel relaxed and enjoy
themselves are our biggest priorities
whether that's in one of our safe
inclusive classroom spaces or continuing
their learning journey at home with our
online learning hub
by turning their natural curiosity into
confidence we make learning english a
fun and memorable adventure growing a
love of learning and self-motivation we
help develop skills they'll use
throughout their lives the british
council has led the way in english
teaching excellence for more than 80
years
now each year more than 400 000 young
learners choose us
all our courses are designed by english
teaching experts and delivered by
passionate inspiring teachers
our qualified specialists get to know
their students personally so they
understand what makes your child special
and what they need at every stage
practical challenges and real world
topics help to get and keep your child
engaged whilst developing their existing
interests plenty of teamwork helps them
gain life skills at the same time as
their spoken english so they begin to
develop the creativity resilience
empathy and critical thinking they will
need later in life you'll be alongside
them on their journey too
we'll provide regular feedback and
guidance on how you can build their
confidence at home through activities on
the learning hub so they come to class
feeling more prepared
what's more they'll be using their new
skills to connect with other young
learners worldwide
our british council primary plus courses
bring classrooms together
so wherever you live your child will be
able to practice speaking english and
sharing stories with students on another
continent
preparing them to discover their place
in a globalized world because we know
it's just the beginning we'll make sure
they are ready to start applying their
new skills in the real world
primary plus helps your child find their
voice